Michael Levin is a distinguished
professor in the biology department at
Tufts University and the holder of the
vanivar Bush endowed chair he's the
director of the Allen Discovery Center
at Tufts and also the center for
regenerative and developmental biology
his research focuses on understanding
the biophysical mechanisms of pattern
regulation and harnessing endogenous
bioelectric Dynamics for rational
control of growth and form
now the capacity to generate a complex
behaving organism from the single cell
of a fertilized egg is one of the most
amazing aspects of biology Levin's lab
integrates approaches from developmental
biology computer science and cognitive
science to investigate the emergence of
Form and Function
Now using biophysical and computational
modeling approaches they seek to
understand the collective intelligence
of cells as they navigate physiological
transcriptional morphogenetic and
behavioral spaces
they develop conceptual Frameworks for
basal cognition and diverse intelligence
including synthetic organisms and AI
also joining us this evening is Arena
Rish arena is a full professor at the
University of Montreal's computer
science and operations research
Department a core member of Miele the
Quebec AI Institute as well as the
holder of the Canada sifar AI chair and
the Canadian Excellence research chair
in autonomous AI
she has a PHD in AI from UC Irvine and
her research focuses on machine learning
neural data analysis Neuroscience
inspired AI continue lifelong learning
optimization algorithms sparse modeling
probabilistic inference dialogue
generation biologically plausible
reinforcement learning and dynamical
systems approaches to brain Imaging
analysis anyway folks I really hope you
enjoy this conversation today so without
any further delay I give you Professor
Michael Levin and Professor Arena Rish
enjoy Michael it's an absolute honor to
meet you
um you've got a very interesting
background now I discovered your work
when we did a show on emergence and I
was looking into graph cellular automata
actually and I was looking into that um
uh the the CNN version which did this
concept called morphogenetic engineering
which is this idea that you can almost
transgress ladders you know like levels
of the emergence ladder by um describing
something at the microscopic scale and
then getting this kind of emergent
Global coherence and in that particular
case it kind of emerged as as the shape
of a gecko I'm not sure if you're
familiar with that particular thing but
um so emergence is fascinating but
coming at it from from your angle in in
biology how do you see the interplay
between what you do in artificial
intelligence
well thanks very much I'm very happy to
be here and have the chance to talk to
you about these things uh a couple of
things
um I think that uh intelligence is uh
baked in basically at the very bottom of
uh the multi-scale architecture that we
have in living organisms and so what I
think is very powerful is this interplay
where we can of course use Ai and
machine learning to try to understand
the biology better and at the same time
we can take all these unconventional
examples of intelligence and cognition
that we find all the way down to
molecular networks and use them as
Inspirations for things that that we
build right either hybrid systems or or
fully engineered
systems and I think one of the key
things to say from my perspective is
that emergence is not the whole story so
I think emergence is very powerful and
emergence certainly happens and we have
many uh many many um scenarios in which
uh highly uh parallel active um
implementation of local Simple Rules
gives you some kind of complex emergent
outcome so we certainly see that but I
think the magic of biology isn't just
that I think uh the real magic of
biology is that at every level these are
not sort of feed forward emergent
processes where you follow the rules
something comes out and you know there
you go whatever comes out comes out I
think that um the key to understanding
the power of biology is that all of
these things at all scales are closed
loop goal directed in the cybernetic
sense not in a magical sort of
Supernatural sense but in the in the
cybernetic sense uh goal-directed agents
that are able to detect error from
specific set points and are doing their
best in terms of using energy and
sometimes actually very clever okay
their policies to achieve specific goals
and specific problem spaces and I think
scaling that up gets us to gets us much
farther than emergence alone
interesting excited I read a book by
Douglas hofstata called The Strange Loop
and he has this idea of all sorts of
interesting causal relations between the
scales and this is something that I find
it a bit difficult to get my head around
so you know the mind for example is an
emergent phenomenon and we have this
thing called agency and I I direct my
hand and I tell my hand to move but if
everything does emerge from the lower
level domain how does that work how do
you get these feedback mechanisms yeah
well a couple of things uh first of all
uh you know this this notion of um
uh reducibility to the lower to the
lower level so so from for a really long
time for centuries this was a
philosophical debate in that people
could argue uh there were there were
reductionists and they would say well
ultimately everything's reducible and
people would say not out there's strong
emergence and things happen at the top
um the amazing thing to me is that this
debate has been actually moved from the
area of philosophy to the area of
mathematics and rigorous science by
people like Julio tanoni and Eric Hull
who have actually uh produced uh new
advances in information Theory where you
can actually calculate which level of
your system does the most work it is no
longer up for philosophical debate you
can actually do the calculation so there
are literally
um there's a software toolkit that you
can use and for a given and sometimes
you will find out that yes indeed it is
reducible to the lower level and if for
other systems you find out that actually
know the higher levels do more work more
causal work than the lower levels and
this has been this has been obvious in
in biology I think for for a really long
time because we as a we as scientists
and Engineers other organisms and in
fact The evolutionary process itself uh
uses higher level
um control knobs exploits them uh very
very significantly the kind of things
that we we for example study is membrane
voltage so resting potential is a kind
of aggregate coarse graining of of the
positions of the individual ions but you
get much further in terms of
regenerative medicine and other
applications if you track the voltage
not the molecular details of the ions it
actually it actually helps you do new
experiments produce Therapeutics uh by
tracking this this high level thing that
that that a reductionist might say well
it doesn't even exist in the first place
so I think so I think these higher
levels absolutely have have causal power
and the way that I would put this
strange Loop idea and I think I think
you know hofstetter has many kind of
ingenious Concepts in his various books
um the way the way I would put the
strange Loop ideas like this
many of the things we are interested in
so so memory cognition
um uh all all these kinds of things in
in my framework I have a particular
framework for thinking about these
things and my framework are Observer
dependent so when you have a particular
system the claim that it occupies some
level along this this Continuum of
agency and I do think it's a Continuum
it's not binary uh the claim that it
occupies some particular
um place along that Continuum is an
observer relevant relative claim in
other words it's not an objective fact
about it it's it's here's an observer
that Observer can formulate some some
particular model of this thing um uh as
a as a as a cognitive agent at some
level of sophistication there's a
different Observer that has a different
model and each of them can interact with
that system well or poorly to the extent
that their model allows and so where you
get the uh where you get the Strange
Loop is that the Observer which is
necessary to Define all you know things
like problem spaces and the goals these
are all Observer dependent The Observer
might be the system itself so so when
you get the real the real boot up of
agency comes when the system becomes its
own Observer and starts to make internal
models of its own parts and and models
that help it uh control itself in its
own in its own lower levels where the
higher levels start to control the lower
levels
yes and that's somewhat reminiscent of
Carl Frist and he has his free energy
principle in the concept of a Markov
blanket and being able to predict
external States probabilistically but
yeah there's two things you said there
so first of all
um this notion of things at different
levels of the emergence ladder doing
different amounts of work and that
suggests to me a kind of form of strong
emergence which is an affront on
physicalism so um I wondered if you
could pick up on on that and the other
thing you said in terms of this Observer
relative thing that gets rather to this
kind of ultra relativistic or even you
know like in the wiccanstinian sense of
or the Putnam sense that you can take
any computation represent it in any
physical system and the kind of the
meaning of that computation is in its
use so it doesn't really have any agency
or valence in of itself
uh yeah yeah so
um I think that uh well the so so the
first question first I guess
um it's only an affront on physicalism
if you assume from the beginning that
physicalism has to be ultimately
reductive so I I I don't believe that to
be the case and so I'm I'm okay with
with a certain kind of physicalism that
does
um that does real Justice to the fact
that uh and they think you know Ian
mcgilkray says this he says uh you know
a lot of physicalists under uh really
really underestimate matter matter is
amazing and it does some amazing things
and when you say wow that can't be you
know matter the you know that that can't
just be matter you're not understanding
what what matter is actually capable of
and I think if we uh take seriously the
fact that yeah it can be matter and also
higher levels of organization can do
work that is not Apparent at lower
levels I think that's totally compatible
um and I'm sorry I forgot what was the
second part
yeah
yeah I think I think that I think that's
that's pretty necessary I think that
gets you very far actually because uh a
lot of times we get stuck in these
pseudo problems when you try to make
objective claims
um about this area you get into real
problems where that that resolve once
you specify from whose Vantage Point are
these things true or false and so you
get into this Observer relativity but I
think it's really really critical to say
that the system itself is also a valid
Observer so it's not just that well you
have no meaning of your own it's up to
us to interpret you I mean we can
interpret you but you can also interpret
yourself and you you're not dependent on
you're not dependent on external
observers to Define these things for you
you are also a bona fide Observer but I
do think and this is work that we've
done with Chris Fields
um the role of an observer in all of
these things I think in the end is is
really critical
wonderful um Arena thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you and uh yeah really good to see
both of you and I'm also looking forward
to uh seeing Michael's talk at their
workshop that we're running next week at
the triple a conference
so uh yeah I enjoyed a bit late uh so
where is there the questions you were
kind of discussing well I just caught
the last one
uh anything
well um so we just did um I'm really
interested in the um the rungs of the
emergence ladder and how different rungs
do different amounts of work they have
complex cause or relationships between
them is it in a fun and a front on
physicalism and reductionism and we're
also talking about this very slippery
notion of agency and where do you draw
the boundary and if if you can draw a
boundary
yeah I mean yeah I was I was saying that
I I I don't even think that it's
primarily an emergence uh Continuum I
think that it's uh well like I call it a
persuadability Continuum but it's
basically it really is a Continuum of
agency and I don't think there are any
sharp boundaries I think sharp
categories are what we as observers
bring to an underlying continuous
phenomenon and we can we can try to
impose categorical boundaries on things
that make it easier for us to do
specific things but the underlying
phenomena I think are are completely
continuous
I I do agree with that and yet
um
there is a notion of transitions in
certain metrics of behavior I'm talking
purely from kind of practical examples
saying behavior of large-scale
um say AI systems neural networks so we
know and that's been observed recently
so that was say scaling the amount of
data or model you might for a while
still not be able to do certain tasks
well and then at some particular kind of
critical size something happens and
model suddenly like grogs it so this
grocking Behavior have been observed
over and over in the past like year and
so in large scale machine learning
models which is essentially kind of
emergence of certain ability
and well I mean it is still continuous
but there is a change in the slope and
the change can be quite dramatic yeah
yeah so yeah so in a sense it also
resonates with other examples where
transitions were happening uh in AI but
not necessarily in machine learning
going all the way back to good old like
uh satisfability problems or constraint
satisfaction problems uh in general even
other it'd be hard problems like
discrete problems where you might have a
network of variables or nodes that can
take different values and you're trying
to basically increase their density in
terms of number of constraints and see
what happens and the property of being
satisfiable problem to unsatisfiable
changes continually but that probability
experiences sharp drop at certain
critical value of say number of
constraints and the system divided by
the number of variables so this
constrainedness plays a role of critical
parameters similar to critical
parameters such as temperature or
pressure in physical systems which
undergo like uh
state of matter transitions with our
water to solid and vice versa and
similar like thermagnetics when the
temperature increases and the
ferromagnetic basically stops being
magnetic and the analogy was made in
some cases quite clearly with those AI
problems at their properties and those
transitions in them it's also kind of
relates closely to like random graph
Theory there is a famous old ethereum by
fried good kalai that if you consider
random graph and say p is probability
that there is an edge in that graph and
that probability keeps increasing when
it's zero the graph is fully
disconnected no Links at all if it's one
everything is connected it's complete
graph in the middle
say if you look at connectedness of a
graph as a property what's the
probability that from any point you can
get to any other point and there is a
pass that's what means graph is
connected that property is probability
again sharply goes from zero to one
around certain critical value of that
parameter and then any other property
what was the duty of that result any
property doesn't have to be connectivity
that's monotonic in age addition welfare
phase transition so though it's
continuous change
the shape of it is highly non-linear
yeah yeah so that's super interesting
and of course of course there are many
phenomena in in physics and and in math
that that show this kind of non-linear
change and that's fine
um I'm interested in how sharp it really
is and and in particular in the cases
that you talked about because what
happens in biology is that uh people
will sort of they look at the adult and
or let's say a human and they say okay
this human has true cognition and you
know real real you know hopes and dreams
and whatnot then they look at the at the
one cell and you know one cell AG at
fertilization they say wow that's just a
chemical system and so the theory is
that at some point right so people
assume that at some point there's some
sort of phase transition and a lot of
people will talk about this phase
transition but if you really uh dig into
this and ask them to specify so so what
is that phase transition right so so in
biology at least in that and the same
thing happens in evolution on The
evolutionary time scale I have never
heard a plausible story of where is it
so so at this moment boom so it's so
that that that thing moved from here to
there ah now we have this like crazy you
know large transition and it's it's
actually quite smooth even though people
tend to assume there must be some kind
of face transition and so I wonder just
out of curiosity because I'm not super
familiar with the examples that you're
talking about if you were to zoom in
right so let's just magnify it so so
clearly you have some sort of sigmoid so
now we're sort of zooming in
how sharp is it actually is there an
atomic operation where I add one Edge to
this graph and Bam now now I'm somewhere
else like how sharp is it really uh yeah
so just like phase Transitions and
statistical physics uh the sharpness
increases with the size of the system
say you have any finite size graph
transition is value or sigmoid when you
grow the size of this graph say you grow
that satisfability problem or whatever
uh the transition becomes sharper and
sharper so in the limit when the system
is infinite that basically the exponent
diverges hmm yeah so it is getting
sharper so yeah in in empirical results
people were kind of doing in constraint
distraction problems satisfability
problems while ago and random graphs
that was happening indeed so as
essentially in similar physical system
sharpness depends on their
size of the model and or the number of
I don't know units particles variables
nodes while the critical parameter is
another thing uh and uh at the same
value of the critical parameter like for
example ratio between constraints and
variables uh the transition happens and
then all the pictures indeed were that
you see sharper and sharper and sharper
for increasing number of variables in
that problem so in a sense
yeah it behaved pretty much just like it
was supposed to behave with certain
physical phenomena uh like uh yeah
phases of
states of matter for example or
paramagnetics like icing models yeah so
yeah it's not always like that I'm not
saying uh well of course people try to
exercise caution when they see rapid
Improvement in uh performance of machine
learning models for example gpt3 or one
particular tasks like arithmetic it was
observed that while on
other tasks and just on measuring how
the loss function during training
behaves it's used to be like quite
common to observe power loss and that
was a famous Chariot couplings and his
colleagues from openai paper around them
basically the scaling laws behavior in
the language models and then they found
in other modalities anyway so it's a
whole field uh Power laws kind of ruled
for a year or so and then people started
digging into more complex behaviors
because for certain tasks like as I said
arithmetic or any
discrete operation that can be described
as a table uh people discovered that
cgpt3 may not do that task well until
certain size and after certain
size of the model it rapidly improves
its performance another example was that
so-called grocking paper also it was in
the IC guy clear workshop and paper I
think was from open AI where they by
mistake just left model running and
training on the data multiple books so
they were not really scaling model or
data but just let it run so compute was
growing and it wasn't doing well the
accuracy was kind of low and at some
point it suddenly later on they saw when
they looked at their uh process they
forgot to kill they looked at it kind of
grogged the problem and at some point it
suddenly improved uh first training loss
and then test loss now there are
multiple groups very actively kind of
studying this phenomenon we got very
interested back in there I guess
September 2021 and submitted the paper
just now
um max tag Mark's group worked on that
and they have some papers now
um Jacob steinhardt from Berkeley they
just had accepted paper at the clear so
anyway people very much got interested
in groking Behavior not necessarily this
specific example but in general when
parameter of Interest which might be
critical
increases on the x-axis it could be a
compute data size model size perhaps
something else and then you have
whatever performance metric on y-axis it
could be accuracy could be loss could be
something else and trying to understand
when those sharp changes may happen and
how sharp they are so so we recently
actually
got this paper at like clear of his my
collaborators with the first author is
Ethan kabalera in the shitish Gupta is
uh second order and uh anyway that
basically trying to fit all these
Strange Behaviors with one functional
form it's so-called broken neural
scaling gloss paper because it's much
richer Behavior than previously assumed
just power loss and those sharp
transitions or not so sharp transitions
are but transitions may happen anyway so
it's a bit maybe of tangent it's about
is there a one functional form to
capture them all but what I'm trying to
say those behaviors keep happening there
is a paper I guess from Stanford like
emerging behaviors and language models
and they show many many empirical
examples of when this type of Behavioral
change happens
needless to say people are very
interested in well you don't have to
call that emergent Behavior but people
interested in
um unexpected changes in performance or
other metrics which may relate to like
AI safety alignment like truthfulness of
this system robustness of the system or
any other property of Interest so it
would be really interesting to
understand better
when and why Behavior may change so this
broken neural Skilling gloss was just
trying to do it as a black box looking
at the system from outside and trying to
statistically predict where it happens
but many people also look inside trying
to understand what dynamics of solutions
can possibly lead to and can allow you
to predict what's about to happen so
actually our studies it seems to be
related to certain oscillation
frequencies in the training laws but you
might be able to tell from the beginning
of the run for given initialization of
system if it's going to grow or not
which is good to know yeah I know I
think I think it's I think it's super
interesting and and of course uh the the
I mean I'm not doubting that these
things exist I what I don't know is to
what extent these are good models for
what goes on in the biology because the
biology seems to be quite continuous
right so these may be two different two
different ways to to look at this and
um and also my sort of big the the
reason I emphasize that the continuity
is not that I want to minimize the
importance of um great transitions
because I do think of course there are
great transitions uh in behavior
um I what I want to do is emphasize the
continuity of substrate because because
a lot of uh do the discourse you know
the the the the the human does this and
the human does that and they say okay so
so which which kind of human like how
far back and you can do this in in
evolutionary scale you can do it in
developmental scale right but eventually
you you follow the human back and you
end up with a single cell and we just
have to deal with the fact that there is
no magic bright line that somebody can
draw okay Boom at this at this point in
embryonic development like that's it now
and is and so and so what we have to
understand of course there can be there
can be um uh uh uh non-monatonic uh you
know non-linear changes and all that but
but it but but but it's a transformation
of the exact same substrate it isn't it
isn't something magical that gets added
at some particular point that and then
everything so so I'm you know I'm sort
of all about that aspect of continuity
it doesn't have to be linear per se but
but we have to come to grips people who
think that that it's crazy to attribute
you know they say it's anthropomorphic
to attribute
um certain kinds of uh cognitive uh
claims to a single cell they owe a story
a very specific story of how you get
from a single cell to a human you can't
simply say that well you know uh there's
some magic that happens in the middle
you actually have to lay out uh what is
it what what's the you know what's the
face transition actually and people sort
of assume there is one but I've never
heard of one I've never heard of a good
one and so so it's quite interesting to
me that these that these do come up in
the in the um in the machine learning
world that's interesting that needs to
come up but there is still
country because yeah I mean you
essentially well to some extent that the
x-axis is well not exactly maybe
absolutely continually growing the size
but for all practical purposes so the
curves are usually always continuous
there is no discontinuous jumps but
continuity with kind of different indeed
uh speed of development dosing change
and uh yeah but I I basically agree with
your point completely that there is no
magic Source or ingredient well unless
you believe in divine intervention or
something like that but yeah if you kind
of keep this hypothesis as more
complicated and prefer simpler based on
just Things You observe then indeed
there is
there is Continuum of intelligence
from human and back to the cell but then
of course a good question is like if you
start decomposing cell and go deep dive
inside yeah then what so so yeah so so
we and other people have have looked at
this and in fact if you look at
something as as
ostensibly uh mechanical as a gene
regulatory Network right so you just
look at a model of genes into turning
each other on and off uh we and and
others have shown that that kind of
thing is capable of six different kinds
of learning including associative
conditioning just just from the
dynamical systems properties of the
Eugene regular regulation nothing else
so there are and now I was just looking
today there is apparently a literature
on um
chemotaxis in individual molecules and
right I I mean I mean uh some of these
things but I think the individual
molecules right and so and and then you
can go below that and the kind of stuff
that we've we've done with Carl friston
and Chris fields and really start
looking at very fundamental particle
interactions as having the sort of
extremely kind of primitive levels of uh
non-zero competencies so so that's it's
a really good question right if you have
a Continuum so the question is there a
zero right is there is there anything
right and you know and and Chris and I
are talking is not intelligent yeah yeah
no it's a that's a great question so so
Chris and I have talked about this and
um because because my claim is is this
if you think about what would the
absolute minimum of intelligence look
like right like what's the what's what's
the absolute minimum and so to me I I
would if I had to come up with the
absolute minimum I would I would lean on
two things I would say I would say the
first thing is uh some level of uh of
goal directedness some ability to pursue
a particular outcome out of a set of
other outcomes and we have this in least
action principles in in even in
particles and then and then some level
of indeterminacy such that local
conditions don't fully determine what
this thing is going to do and we have
that in particles and so I would claim
that it doesn't actually bottom out at
zero even at the atomic scale and so I
said to Chris one day um could we have a
world with no leased action laws that
where where it literally would be zero
and he his he what he said was uh yes
but it would have to be a universe in
which nothing ever happened so it would
have to be a completely static universe
that one one the in which things happen
you're going to be able to to derive
some sort of
um least action kind of thing which
looks like the basement of cognition to
me
yeah very interesting
so
it was always kind of an open question
how to
link this to what people are say doing
right now developing uh like artificial
neural networks and those systems uh
basically how that would translate in AI
domain what would it mean for this
modeling like can we indeed well I mean
I think people did try to Define
intelligence and its units although
it's not something that people commonly
use like I I wouldn't claim that there
were no such attempts but nevertheless
I mean we still not
really doing that uh and uh here and
there people say well probably should be
measuring uh more formally what we want
from our model in terms of intelligence
and what how those things compare and
can you say that it's as intelligent as
like that type of the organism or this
or yeah so some
basically making this whole engineering
field a bit more of a
science like well physics or even
biology in terms of
in order to make claim that something is
intelligent would be at least good to
Define it more formally
again going back to physics and have
some
notion of units or something so you can
say that in that units you can say this
is larger than that yeah yeah yeah so so
something like predictive accuracy of
models can be a proxy for that
yeah um so Chris and I tackled this in a
in a recent paper is starting off with
the idea that making claims about
something the intelligence of something
is really taking an IQ test ourselves
because you have to be smart enough to
to to to to to to pick a problem space
and identify the the uh the degree of
cleverness of the policy that the system
is following in that space and and and
you may not see it right it's not
obvious that we can always detect it and
so in biology we are very used to seeing
mid-sized objects moving at medium
speeds in three-dimensional space and
saying oh look you know look at what
that Crow is doing that's intelligent
but there are other spaces right so
physiological space metabolic space is a
transcriptional space um anatomical
amorphous space which my lab studies uh
cells and tissues do amazing things in
those spaces that are absolutely if if
that if they they navigate those spaces
in a way that if we had a robot or an
autonomous vehicle doing that this would
be off the charts uh performance and and
and and it's not in the fee it's not in
the domain of classical
three-dimensional Behavior it's it's
behavior in these other spaces and
learning to recognize that is very hard
for us because as humans all of our
sense organs sort of tend to point
outwards if you had a if you had an
innate feeling of your blood chemistry
you would know without a doubt that your
liver and your kidneys were intelligent
because you could you would see how they
navigate that space you would directly
feel it the way that we currently see
each other in Africa and say Ah that's
pretty clever you know so so so the
right so so so what we try to do is to
lay out
um and this was this was it goes back to
like the 40s you know Weiner and
rosenbluth had this the scale right of
of from all the way from passive
materials all the way up to second order
like um you know metacognition and
whatnot and everything in between the
kinds of competencies that different
systems have in navigating these spaces
and one way to do it is uh and I I
repeat this quote a lot and I wish I
could remember who said it but somebody
said this it's it's the Continuum
between the way the two magnets try to
get together and how Romeo and Julia try
to get together right what's the
difference the difference is in the
degree of ability to overcome obstacles
along the way so so you can be extremely
simple and all you know how to do is go
down an energy gradient and magnets can
can do that or you can be extremely
complex and be able to but in the middle
there's all this there's all this stuff
right and so you can kind of start and
and we this is what we do experimentally
we put these systems in ways where we
start to challenge their normal behavior
and we find very surprising thing things
that we that people always thought were
like hardwired and and just sort of uh
you know this is well of course this is
you know it's it's all it knows how to
do is things rolling downhill and that's
it once you start to challenge it with
various perturbations then you get to
find out what it actually knows how to
do and then you can form specific
hypotheses does it you know how far
ahead can it plan does it see does it
have a memory does it you know you can
but the way you find out is by
challenging all these things and you
know like um like the frog face example
and and and many other things you find
you you you find out that these things
are actually way more clever than than
they seem at first you know
yeah I definitely remember
how you gave the talk in December 2013
that in Europe's World bodies think
about and the message to people studying
neural networks that
yeah intelligence was there way before
the first neuron appeared so
maybe we should look but still the
common part was networks they doesn't
have to be neural they don't have to be
neural but like essentially I I do
remember all these experiments were
essentially about changing the network
communication so that their organism as
a whole or the part of it
changes its form to whatever you kind of
wanted it to be but I think even if we
scratch neurals from that
the key essence of
kind of phenomenon will be always
Network
I mean I would I would yes but I would
extend that to say that it can't be a
single level of of um of organization
right so so in biology the trick is that
every network is a network of networks
and each one is as goal directedness so
every every level is trying to
accomplish specific things in specific
spaces and they all cooperate or compete
with each other so uh you know this this
is another talk that I give sometimes
why it's called why robots don't get
cancer right why why don't why don't our
robotics get cancer and and and and it's
it's because they're not made of parts
that have the capacity to go off on
their own and do their own thing in
biology every single part is basically
being held against its will by the level
above so everything if you were to just
like release the top levels goal
directedness the parts would go off and
do other things and sometimes they do
and then we get phenotypes like cancer I
I remember really well though I've had
this uh five hour discussion in the IBM
research cafeteria in Yorktown a few
years ago and yeah really it's a very
insightful making analogy between kind
of their cell going cancers or coming
back to its senses and essentially the
notion of at what scale the objective of
the cell to survive and thrive is
applied because yeah if you single cell
in the environment you treat it as a
source of food it's environment right
yeah but if you become part of the
organism yeah you're under pressure to
behave in the best interest of organism
if you forget about that due to changes
in your communication with other members
of organism Society then you start
acting uh selfishly and too bad that's
cancer
could I could I put a quick question to
you Michael because you've I'm very
interested in the definition of
intelligence and you're saying words
like uh goal directedness
um agents planning and these terms are a
little bit anthropomorphic but you could
argue that they are Universal Primitives
and you're also talking along the lines
of Intelligence being almost like uh I
mean some people describe it as as
capability or with an underlying
principle
but it's almost like it's a Continuum
and there are people who believe that
humans are special we think you know the
behaviorists thought that it was just a
very simple stimulus response the
monkeys don't have a flash of
inspiration they don't plan how to get
the banana we have something different
what do you think
well uh I I I'm I'm I'm I'm certainly
not saying that we don't think or that
there is no material difference between
us and and let's say a paramecium so the
the differences are of course real I I I
insist on one thing and then and then I
have hypotheses about our other stuff
the thing that I insist on is that uh
when we make a
um a claim about the level of cognition
of some system real artificial you know
it evolved artificial whatever
you cannot make those claims from an
armchair you have to do experiments and
so you cannot have feelings about these
things people say to me all the time oh
well you know with xenobots well it's
frogsky and that can't XYZ you know you
name it whatever it can and say well how
did you arrive at this conclusion you
cannot just have feelings about this
stuff you have to do experiments and
when you do experiments as we found and
and other people have found you get
surprised because it is not obvious uh
what the capabilities of something is
until you start to perturb it and see
what happens and the thing and and to to
to find out so so in order to make an
intelligence claim you need a couple
things you need to pick a space within
which you think it's solving problems
right so so you as the Observer have to
make have to say I think this is the
space in which it works then you have to
say here is the goal I think this thing
is pursuing in a cybernetic sense and
then you have to say and now I have a
hypothesis about how clever this is what
can it do can it go around obstacles is
it Trap by local Minima does it have
path history does it have this that you
make some sort of some sort of claim
having made those three claims we can
then empirically see how well does that
work out for you what does that enable
you to do and so then then multiple
observers so so someone can come along
and say you're crazy this thing doesn't
have any of that somebody else can say
oh no it's actually much more clever
than that and then we all interact with
the system and we see who wins it's in a
it's a it's it's an empirical question
that has to be put so the only thing
that that I insist on is that uh this
charge of anthropomorphism
um it has to be quite specific we have
to make a specific claim what do we
think this thing is able to do and then
we get to find out is is that a useful
lens onto the system or not
okay but just a quick follow-up I mean
what what is it because a goal feels
like it's a wicked form of reductionism
along the lines of we what we were
talking about before and even it because
you know Shane Legg has this idea that
the definition of intelligence is an
agent being able to solve a variety of
tasks in different environments and so
on and and even if there were such a
goal why would it be intelligible to us
uh I I don't believe that there is an
objective goal that is intelligible in
the sense that we get to discover it
once and for all and then we're done I
think that when when somebody says uh
that this system has a particular goal
what they're saying is they have
discovered a a lens a perspective on the
behavior such that
um positing that it has a goal and some
set of competencies to reach that goal
gives you increased ability to predict
and control that system so so so so here
so so we come across the thermostat and
um you look at this thing and uh you
know you're you're a reductionist then
you say well okay uh I can sort of
calculate uh what what all the particles
are doing and that's great and I look at
it and say hmm I see this and this and I
think this is the set point and you say
there's no such thing as a set point
there's just atoms in the thing and I
say well well here's the thing though I
I will exert much less energy and effort
in changing the temperature of the room
while you're running around pushing on
all the individual you know atoms that
of this thing I'm just going to change
the set point and let the thing take
care of itself so so the level of what
what it affords you is a a more powerful
level of relationship to the system for
simple systems that's prediction and
control for complex systems that may be
uh everything from from training to
Friendship to who knows you're right for
complex system what we're looking at is
um what level of agency gives me the
best interaction with the system and I
can I can guess too high right if I'm
standing there arguing you know pleading
with my thermostats you know here are
all the reasons you should change like
that's not going to work and at the same
time if if I have a a system that's a
that's a learning agent like you know a
horse or a dog uh humans thousands of
years ago figured out that you don't
need to know the Neuroscience of what's
between their ears you can train the
thing and right so so you found an
interface that that that allows you to
do amazing things because you understood
that this is not the same as as a
complex as you know set of bowling balls
that you would have to engineer bottom
up so so that that's all these things
are just meant to be I don't I I don't
believe there's anything that I don't
believe there's any such thing as
anthropomorphism anthropomorphism sounds
to me like we're still working with a
Garden of Eden story that that you've
got a human the human has this magic
glow about them and trying to uh uh sort
of sort of shade that into other things
is is a you know is a major
transgression I don't buy it I think
that what you have to do is you have to
make very specific claims this human or
this robot or this cell can do XYZ and
then we find out it can or it can't and
and then we you know we sort of
empirically we know did we guess
correctly did we overdo it did we under
under appreciate it in in my experience
we tend to under appreciate intelligence
way more than we over appreciate it
that's just that's just what I see in in
the biosciences
yeah I I do agree with the point that uh
is perhaps uh humans ego would like to
think that there is something absolutely
special in humans and that's on but
indeed I mean the Continuum is there
so and humans developed
from something much simpler and they
inherited properties of that
and uh yeah so basically I think I think
it's much better probably even for the
field of artificial intelligence it
would be much better to look at the
intelligence from this perspective
rather than from there well as you said
Garden of Eden type of
and uniqueness of human abilities I mean
Intelligence being just really bound to
Being Human
yeah yeah I mean I'm certainly not
arguing that that the humans have some
interesting capacities that are that are
hard or impossible to find elsewhere
right now but this this way of thinking
about them as natural kinds as sharp
natural kinds I think is is
philosophically really problematic
because biology is so so I have this
diagram that I sort of beat people over
the head with and and it's got It's got
like a standard human in the center
right and then up above is a is a very
high resolution uh evolutionary Series
going all the way back to you know you
name it some sort of some sort of
microbe right and so whatever you think
this human has you have to tell me where
it Peters out like where what where did
you have these two parents that were not
whatever right the gentle and then bam
they had a child and now the child has
you know true whatever like where is
that line that's impossible then down
below it's got the same sort of thing
developmentally so again I could take
you all the way back to the Single Cell
oocyte a little pile of chemicals and
you have to tell me where things Peter
out if they do and then laterally it
gets even worse because uh in One
Direction what you can do is you by
biology is so interoperable you can
start to make um chimeras and hybrids
between biological tissues and uh and
machines so we can make you I can have
over here somebody that's uh you know 99
human and a little bit of you know chips
in the brain right uh with some AI over
here it's the Opposites 99 Roomba with
some human brain cells living in it that
sort of are instrumented to it and we
can fill in every single point in the
middle every point in the middle is is
is occupied by a possible being 50 50
you know 63 64. you you name it right
and and if you're saying this is a
machine and this is a human and these
are binary categories then you got a
real problem telling me where we're
going to shift over right where are we
going to click over and the same thing
with the on the biological the
bioengineering and so so so here's a
human at some point we're going to want
some gills and somebody's gonna want to
tail and somebody's going to want a
third brain hemisphere all of this is
completely doable completely doable and
we could we could do we could do much of
this to you know tomorrow and so uh then
again you have to tell me what's where
are they when are they not human anymore
I feel like you know these these
categories are
um treating them as As Natural kinds is
is limiting more than it is facilitating
for for ideas in this field well we very
kind of clearly going into transhumanism
yeah which is indeed quite a natural
progression
because you yeah you keep extending your
capabilities with any kind of automation
or tools starting from glasses or
whatever and yeah you keep extending
yourself you keep morphing with it and
indeed it's a good question like okay so
yeah what is a what is the line there
are of course many interesting
controversial questions about that we
probably should not go into that because
it's kind of worms
of all the things that we discussed I
can only imagine questions coming from
that side
I I one of my favorite stories I came
across is the first guy to use an
umbrella in London right I mean this was
considered scandalous he was pelted with
garbage because it was he was upsetting
the natural order of things that wow who
is he not to get wet this is unnatural
we're all walking around under the rain
getting wet and look at this guy there
was an umbrella and right and so I you
know I didn't know this story yeah yeah
yeah yeah well it's I mean look I got it
off the internet so so maybe it's I
assume okay who knows definitely use
this story in some of my arguments thank
you people I I I get I get this from
people all the time oh my God it's you
know it's it's on you know it's
unnatural look natural is getting is
getting scratched in the forest getting
an infection and dying because you don't
you know because you got scratched or
because you we don't know how to brush
our teeth like natural is terrible
natural is absolutely terrible and and
we can do better we can do better than
this and and I think that um you know
all of these all of these things are
going to be people are gonna people are
gonna laugh at us in the future I think
thinking about the things that we were
concerned with here the same way that we
think of you know back in the day the
first person to come up with some
crutches or or some you know glasses I
mean uh you know this kind of stuff it's
just it's just yeah I don't know I don't
know yeah that's that's flash of
inspiration
yeah
another argument could be well what is
really a natural blog if we are natural
and naturally our brains are coming up
with those extensions they are natural
therefore as well sure sure I think all
of this stuff is you know all of this
stuff I think even even in in in very
modern you know sort of scientific
thinkers a lot of the stuff goes back to
a Garden of Eden view of if it was the
case that somebody has prepped all of
this for us in the best possible way
then of course the answer is hey you
scientists don't screw it up it's
already as good as it's going to be all
you're going to do is make it worse that
made sense when people thought that this
was all created for us in the best
possible way that picture that that
story as as has crumbled long ago
there's no way I think rationally to
look around at
um the the health disparities worldwide
the um the the incredible suffering due
to disease and aging and everything else
and to say that well natural is
fantastic let's just make sure that okay
natural is horrible and and and up until
now there's there's been no way to get
around it now finally we have you know
we're the adults in the room now we we
have some of it and of course we're
going to mess things up too of course
but but we have now some ability to do
better than natural and let's just
remember that natural is not someone has
prepped this for us uh you know in
accordance to our values of happiness
and fulfillment all that nobody's done
that Evolution Evolution uh optimizes
for biomass basically like that's it
that's it it doesn't optimize for
intelligence really it doesn't optimize
for happiness for any of those things
Evolution just make sure that the next
Observer is going to observe a bunch of
um stuff you know running around in
interesting things that's it that's it
all right so I I really vividly remember
when you first shown the videos with
those flat worms that preventable flat
worms by now and essentially once you
get the two-headed of three credit and
those kind of uh tractors in the space
of the dynamic assist something at this
table right they replicate and they are
still two-headed and essentially say
well one head at one was a solution some
local minimum found by evolutionary
stochastic gradient descent or you name
it and it could have been another
solution and another solution and some
of them maybe have lower loss or higher
reward or whatever right so why won't we
just look for them yeah yeah
yeah so that was quite an eye-opener yet
yet
uh it's very strong
bias against transhumanism quite often
and um right it's understandable because
the chances of kind of screwing things
up are definitely non-zero sure but they
are also not 100 yeah I think the
difference between people is in their
kind of estimation whether the glass is
half full or half empty it's also it's
that and it's also so so I get a lot of
phone calls every week and I get two
kinds of phone calls uh the young
healthy people are calling me saying
knock this off it's like it's it's scary
it's dangerous whatever the people with
various medical problems or with
children with medical problems call me
yelling uh what's taking you so long
like hurry up we have problems like we
need and so you know and I just always
want to like try to connect these people
to each other because because you know
of of yeah of everything's all well and
good until until you need to go to the
doctor and then you hope they figured
some of this out uh it's it's you know
it's all scary until until you need
something and yeah something new and
much scarier happens to you yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's just stop being
scared of imaginary things yeah that's
that's that's yeah that's that's exactly
right
yeah and and change you know change is
scary too and and I and the interesting
thing about about change the fundamental
changes that your values can change I re
I distinctly remember being being a
young kid looking at some of the older
kids and thinking wow uh you know and
they you know they were they you know
they're dating and all this stuff I'm
like oh my God I'm gonna I'm gonna have
to um it looks it will be based on what
I see here I'm gonna end up like one of
them and then I'm just gonna be
interested in all this kind of crazy
stuff that I have zero this is this is
unbelievable what is there a way to like
like not do that and and of course but
then of course once you make that
transition you think well that was dumb
because now I like all this stuff and
and so you can you know it's it's scary
because when you change the things that
are important to you will change
yeah well the good thing is once you
change
you will not care anymore about the
videos you had before you change exactly
at least it will go along with that
because yeah I remember like before I
had first child like everybody would say
oh now you're gonna be crazy busy you
will not have time for work forget about
friends you'll just have no time for
anything and it look like oh my gosh
it's awful then you transition and say
well but they don't care about that
stuff anymore I care about this and I'm
happy as well and that's it so yeah
amazing yeah amazing well um Professor
Michael Levin and Professor Irina ish
it's been an absolute honor to have you
on today thank you so much yeah really
thank you so much
good to meet you good good to see you